This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Over the past month, we've all had to make some adjustments to try to stop the spread of COVID-19. Some of them have been small, like me recording this episode, I aren't either comforter in my bedroom instead of in our studio, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. I mean, that experience is unique to me, but another adjustment that I've made and one that you probably had to make too, is wearing a mask in public. If you've been paying attention to the directives about where and when, or even who, should be wearing masks, then there's a good chance you've been a little confused because they've changed dramatically.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在过去的一个月里，我们所有人都不得不做出一些调整，试图阻止新冠肺炎的传播。其中一些调整很小，比如我是在卧室里的舒适被窝里录制这一集，而不是在位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的演播室里。我的意思是，这种经历对我来说是独一无二的，但我做出的另一个调整，也是你可能也不得不做的调整，就是在公共场合戴口罩。如果你一直关注关于在哪里、何时甚至谁应该戴口罩的指令，那么你很有可能会感到有些困惑，因为这些指令发生了巨大的变化。
Here in the US, we're just not used to needing to cover half of our faces in public, but if you look at the other side of the world, it's a different story. In parts of Asia, where a mask and response to the coronavirus pandemic was a totally easy and normal adjustment. Rebecca Canther is a reporter based in Shanghai who was lived in China for the past 17 years, And she is here to tell us why the culture of masks developed so differently there. And the doctor, who started it all. Yeah, I remember the first time I really started taking this seriously. I was traveling on my way home to see my in-laws actually for Chinese New Year. And the night before I'd gone out,
在美国，我们根本不习惯在公众场合遮住半边脸，但如果你看看世界其他地方，情况就完全不同了。在亚洲的一些地方，戴口罩以应对冠状病毒大流行是一个完全轻松且正常的调整。丽贝卡·坎瑟是一位驻上海的记者，在过去的17年里她一直住在中国，她来到这里是为了告诉我们，为什么那里的口罩文化发展得如此不同，以及这一切的发起者。是的，我记得我真正开始认真对待这件事的第一次。当时我正坐车回家去看望公婆，正好赶上中国农历新年。就在前天晚上我出门的时候，
everything was normal. And then that morning I'd gone out, everything was normal. And then that morning, I walked out the door and I put the location on my GPS app on my phone. And you know how on your phone, the GPS app will tell you in this nice, calm voice, which direction to start off in. Well, this time, my GPS app said this. So it's saying, please wear a mask if you're going out. Be safe. Wow. I don't think my GPS has ever been quite that intimate with me before.
一切都很正常。然后那天早上我出门了，一切都很正常。然后那天早上，我走出门外，在手机的GPS应用上输入了目的地。你知道手机上的GPS应用会用那种好听、平静的声音告诉你该朝哪个方向出发吗？嗯，这一次，我的GPS应用是这样说的。它是说，如果你要出门，请戴上口罩。请注意安全。哇。我想我的GPS以前从来没有对我这么亲近过。
Yeah. My phone's never gotten that personal with me before. I mean, it's like totally weird. So it's stuck with me. And then you know after I heard that, then I you know I was looking around and I started noticing everyone around me on the street was wearing a mask. It was like between the day before and that day like a switch had been flipped. Everyone knew exactly what to do. So a week later I got back to Shanghai and the change was just even more drastic.
是的。我的手机以前从没有对我有过这么私密的关怀。我的意思是，这真是太奇怪了。所以它一直留在我脑海里。然后你知道，在我听到这个之后，我环顾四周，开始注意到街上的每个人都在戴口罩。这就像在前一天和那天之间，仿佛有人按下了开关。每个人都知道该做什​​么。所以一周后我回到上海，变化甚至更加剧烈。
You know people weren't going outside but anyone who did go outside was wearing a mask and there were posters all over reminding people to wear masks and I was riding my bike one day and I passed this loudspeaker with a voice that was just like on a loop reminding people to wear a mask. And so the thing is, like everyone has to wear a mask, but at that time you couldn't buy one anywhere. Like the pharmacies were all sold out. I mean, I tried online. So does that mean that everyone just already had a mask? Yeah, I guess. I mean, I think people had masks at home. So, I mean, eventually a friend gave me some, which was really nice.
你知道，人们不出门，但任何出门的人都戴着口罩，到处都是提醒人们戴口罩的海报。有一天我骑着自行车，经过一个扬声器，里面循环播放着提醒人们戴口罩的声音。所以问题是，就像每个人都必须戴口罩一样，但当时你在任何地方都买不到口罩。所有的药店都卖光了。我的意思是，我在网上试过了。那是不是意味着每个人都已经有口罩了？是的，我猜是的。我的意思是，我想人们家里都有口罩。所以，最后有个朋友送了我一些，这真的很暖心。
But the whole experience got me wondering, like, how come everybody else was so prepared? And I'm like the only idiot. Like, got caught off guard. I mean, right. I mean, it seems like, I mean, you're from the US and I'm here in the US and we just seem to have a very different relationship with masks in general. Yeah, I mean, it's like nothing that I counted as something I should keep in my first aid kid at home, but I guess everyone else here was doing that. And so why do you think that is?
但整个经历让我纳闷，为什么其他人准备得这么充分？而我却像个唯一措手不及的笨蛋。我是说，对吧。我的意思是，看起来，你来自美国，而我在这里也在美国，我们对口罩的整体态度似乎有很大不同。是的，我的意思是，这根本不属于我列为应该放在家里的急救包里的东西，但我猜这里的其他人都在这么做。所以你觉得这是为什么？
Why does China have a different relationship with masks? Yeah, I mean, I was really curious about that so I started looking into the history of masks in China. And it turns out they've been used here for a really long time. So Roman, I sent you a photo on the Zoom chat. Do you have it there? Yeah, so this is a black and white photo. It's a couple people wearing. You know, big white mask, like everything is kind of covered except for the eyes, but it's like a little thicker and gauzeer than the ones that we might see people wearing around today, but it's basically the same principle, you know, it's a mask. So when was this photo taken?
为什么中国对口罩有不同的态度？是的，我的意思是，我对此真的很好奇，所以我开始研究中国口罩的历史。事实证明，它们在这里已经使用了很长时间。所以，罗曼，我在Zoom聊天里给你发了一张照片。你那儿有吗？是的，这是一张黑白照片。是几个人在戴着。你知道，大大的白口罩，除了眼睛之外，其他地方都遮得严严实实，但它比我们今天看到的大家戴的要厚一点、更像纱布一些，不过基本原理是一样的，你知道，这就是个口罩。那么这张照片是什么时候拍的？
So this photo is from over a hundred years ago. When China was the scene of another devastating epidemic, the Great Manchurian Plague. Manchurian at the time was contested territory. It's where Northeastern China is today, and in 1910 it became the site of a really deadly outbreak of plague. 95% or more of those that got infected died, and they died fast within just a few days of contracting the virus.
所以这张照片是一百多年前拍的。当时中国正经历另一场毁灭性的流行病——东北鼠疫。当时的东北是争议领土。也就是今天的中国东北，1910年，这里爆发了一场极其致命的鼠疫。95%或更多的感染者死亡，而且死得很快，在感染病毒后的短短几天内就死亡了。
And this outbreak was really well documented, especially in photographs. It was the first time that you had cameras that could readily cover an epidemic, but also it was the first time that newspapers could carry these images, you know, could carry good quality photographic images. So this is Christos Linteres. He's a medical anthropologist at University of St. Andrews in the UK. And he said that at that time, photos of the outbreak
这次疫情有很好的记录，特别是在照片方面。那是第一次有相机能够全面报道疫情，这也是第一次报纸能够刊登这些图像，你知道，能够刊登高质量的照片图像。这位是克里斯托斯·林特雷斯。他是英国圣安德鲁斯大学的医学人类学家。他说，当时，
in Manchuria were seen in newspapers around the world. And photography played a key role in establishing this idea of a global outbreak, you know, an outbreak, which is spreading across the globe. So a lot of these photographs were quite graphic scenes of victims, but there were also a lot of photographs of people wearing masks, like the one I showed you. And at the center of this photography is the mask.
东北疫情的照片在世界各地的报纸上都能看到。摄影在确立全球疫情这一概念方面发挥了关键作用，也就是正在全球蔓延的疫情。因此，许多照片都是受害者的相当生动的场景，但也有很多人们戴着口罩的照片，就像我给你看的那样。而所有这些摄影的中心就是口罩。
Now why the mask? Masks have been used before for surgery. So I think the official history of the mask in a clinical setting or on the operation theater dates back from around 1897. But masks have never been systematically used in an epidemic before. So masks had been used by doctors,
那为什么是口罩呢？以前外科手术也用过口罩。所以我想临床或手术室中使用口罩的官方历史可以追溯到1897年左右。但以前在流行病中从没有系统地使用过口罩。所以医生使用过口罩，
but they weren't being used by the general public at this point. Right. But that changed in Manchuria because of one guy. His name was Julienta. Dr. Wu was a young Chinese Malaysian doctor who had gone abroad to study medicine in Europe, and he was actually the first ethnic Chinese person to study at Cambridge. The Qing Dynasty government called him in to lead the Chinese efforts against the plague since it was an international effort.
但在当时，普通公众并没有使用。没错。但在东北，由于一个人，这一切改变了。他的名字叫伍连德。伍博士是一位年轻的马来西亚籍华人医生，曾出国到欧洲学医，他实际上是第一个在剑桥大学学习的中国血统的人。由于这是一项国际合作，清廷政府邀请他领导中国的抗鼠疫工作。
And he was surrounded by all these much more experienced doctors from Russia, Japan, France, Great Britain. And he was only in his early thirties, but he was really smart. And he was a brilliant scientist. And he soon came across the paper with symptoms and he concluded, okay, this is a pneumonic plague. And he had this idea that it spread in an airborne manner. So, meaning it spread from droplets in the air coming from people's noses or mouths.
当时他身边都是来自俄罗斯、日本、法国、英国的经验丰富的医生。他才三十出头，但真的很聪明。他是一位杰出的科学家。不久，他看到了一篇关于症状的论文，并得出结论：好吧，这是肺鼠疫。他提出了这样一个想法：它是通过空气传播的。也就是说，它通过人们鼻子或嘴巴产生的空气中的飞沫传播。
And was this a new idea? I mean, how did people think it was being spread at the time? Well, you know, there's different kinds of plague. There's bubonic and seemick. Those ones are spread by fleas from small animals. And at the time, most of the experts thought that was how this plague was spreading. But Dr. Wu, he figured out that this outbreak was a different kind of plague. I mean, he was treating all these people with respiratory symptoms. And he was convinced that the plague bacteria was spreading through the air. And he was right about it. I'm going to go Dr. Wu.
这是一个新概念吗？当时人们认为它是如何传播的？嗯，你知道，鼠疫有不同的种类。有腺鼠疫和败血症鼠疫。这些是由小型动物身上的跳蚤传播的。当时，大多数专家认为这就是鼠疫传播的方式。但伍博士发现，这次爆发的是一种不同类型的鼠疫。我的意思是，他一直在治疗所有这些有呼吸道症状的人。他坚信鼠疫杆菌是通过空气传播的。关于这一点，他是对的。真为伍博士点赞。
Yeah. And so he made us, like it seemed like a simple suggestion. Everyone should start covering their mouth and noses with face masks. Right, which is the suggestion that we're all getting today to stop this part of coronavirus. Right, but that was the first time someone had suggested that. And he was really serious about this idea. He designed face masks himself. And so I talked to this historian at Shanghai Library. Her name's Vivienne Huang. And she's been researching the history of Wu's mask.
是的。所以他提出了一个看似简单的建议。每个人都应该开始用口罩遮住口鼻。没错，这也就是我们今天为了阻止新冠病毒传播而得到的建议。没错，但那是第一次有人提出这个建议。而且他对这个想法非常认真。他自己设计了口罩。所以我采访了上海图书馆的一位历史学家。她叫黄维雯。她一直在研究伍连德口罩的历史。
And she was telling me about how it was designed. She speaks Chinese, so I'm just gonna translate what she said. This is how it is. It's like this. She said it was this basic gauze mask with two layers. And in between the layers, there was about a four by six inch piece of cotton that was about a half inch thick. And then there were these two strings to tie the mask behind your head.
她向我介绍了它是如何设计的。她说中文，所以我来翻译她的话。事情就是这样的。它就像这样。她说，这是一种基本的两层纱布口罩。两层之间有一块大约四乘六英寸、大约半英寸厚的棉花。然后有两根系带把口罩系在脑后。
And all of these materials were really cheap and easy to find at the time. So it was something that was meant to be very simple, very easy and cheap to produce, and which he envisioned that all his doctors, all his nurses and all his sanitary staff should use while engaged in anti-plague operations. And he wants the general public to wear these masks as well. But the other doctors in Manchuria at the time, they wouldn't listen to him. I mean, maybe it was because he was young or maybe because China at that time wasn't really known for its scientific prowess, they just didn't believe him.
当时所有这些材料都很便宜而且很容易找到。因此，这是一种旨在非常简单、非常容易且廉价生产的东西，他设想他所有的医生、所有的护士和所有的卫生人员在从事抗疫工作时都应该使用它。他也希望普通公众也戴这些口罩。但当时东北的其他医生根本不听他的。我的意思是，也许是因为他年轻，或者也许是因为中国当时在科学实力上并不出名，他们就是不相信他。
Or maybe it's because they're racist. No, but even the local leaders were suspicious of him. I mean, he was just nobody believed him. And I think it was because he was kind of a nobody compared to all these famous European and Japanese doctors. So they antagonized him very, very actively and there is this incident which he recounts in his autobiography which is called the plague fighter, where he's confronted by a famous French doctor, Gerard Mazzini. And Mazzini hears who, expanding his airborne plague theory, and he humiliates him in a very racist manner.
或者也许是因为他们有种族歧视？不，甚至连当地的领导人都对他产生怀疑。我的意思是，根本没有人相信他。我想这是因为与所有这些著名的欧洲和日本医生相比，他简直是个无名小卒。所以他们非常非常积极地与他作对，在他的自传《鼠疫斗者》中就记录了这样一件事：他遭到了法国著名医生杰拉德·梅尼的质问。梅尼听到伍连德阐述空气传播鼠疫的理论时，以非常带有种族歧视的方式羞辱了他。
And then Mazzini goes on to operate in, you know, in one of the hospitals to attend the sick. Without wearing what Wu had suggested is an essential device, which is the mask. So I think you can guess where this is going. Unfortunately for the French doctor, he dies soon after. I have just played and he dies. So who is suddenly and completely unexpectedly, for most people, vindicated? Wow, that is a traumatic.
然后梅尼继续在其中一家医院进行手术以照顾病人。却没有佩戴伍连德所说的必不可少的防护装备——口罩。我想你大概能猜到接下来会发生什么。不幸的是，这位法国医生不久后就去世了。我刚说完他就去世了。那么，对大多数人来说，伍连德突然且完全出乎意料地沉冤得雪了吗？哇，这太戏剧性了。
Yeah, I mean, we don't know if the mask would have saved him, but after he died, it was just this huge case and point that proved that who had been right. So the moment when Mizzini dies and basically everyone starts accepting who's theory, you know, this mask goes viral. I don't know if I'll ever be able to use that phrase quite the same way as I used to, but I get his point at this point like it just spreads everywhere. Yeah, exactly. I mean, it was reported on all over the world.
是的，我的意思是，我们不知道口罩是否能救他的命，但在他死后，这成了一个极好的例证，证明伍连德是对的。就在梅尼死的那一刻，基本上所有人都开始接受伍连德的理论，你知道，这款口罩火了。我不知道我以后还能不能像以前那样自然地使用这个词，但我现在理解他的意思了，就是它到处传播开来。对，完全如此。我的意思是，世界各地都对此进行了报道。
The Manchurian plague ended after seven months. Some people say it ended because spring came and the weather warmed up. But Dr. Wu claimed victory because of the recommendations he made to stop it spread, wearing masks, quarantining sick patients, cutting off the trans-siberian railway lines. But Dr. Wu's mask became the symbol for successfully controlling the outbreak. Everyone wants the mask, and everyone starts photographing the mask. And the mask becomes this kind of symbol of scientific success and medical ability to cope with this dreadfully disease in Manchuria, and Woo is praised, of course, as a genius in having invented it.
东北鼠疫在七个月后结束了。有人说是因为春天来了，天气变暖了。但伍连德宣称取得了胜利，这归功于他为阻止其传播而提出的建议：戴口罩、隔离生病的患者、切断西伯利亚大铁路。但伍连德的口罩成为了成功控制疫情的象征。每个人都想要口罩，每个人都开始给口罩拍照。口罩成为了东北地区科学成功和医疗能力应对这种可怕疾病的一种象征，伍连德当然被誉为发明口罩的天才。
So it's a huge success story for Wu. And he came out of this as, you know, the guy who was internationally recognized as having control of the epidemic, which was astonishing because he was a nobody until then. And he was competing with very, very famous doctors. Dr. Wu went on to form China's first organization dealing with disease control. And then later he formed the Chinese Medical Association. His work is the basis for China's disease control
所以对伍连德来说这是一个巨大的成功故事。他从中脱颖而出，成为了国际公认控制了这场疫情的人，这令人震惊，因为在此之前他只是个无名小卒。他当时正与非常非常著名的医生竞争。伍连德后来组建了中国第一个传染病控制组织。后来他又组建了中华医学会。他的工作构成了中国疾病控制
and public health system today. And do people remember him today? I mean, did he get the recognition that he deserved? Well, I mean, in 1935, he was nominated for a Nobel Prize. Well, that's pretty good. Yeah, okay. But today, I mean, he never became a household name, not even in China.
和公共卫生体系的基石。那人们今天还记得他吗？我的意思是，他得到了他应得的认可吗？嗯，我的意思是，1935年，他被提名诺贝尔奖。嗯，那挺不错的。是的，好吧。但今天，我的意思是，他从未成为一个家喻户晓的名字，甚至在中国都不是。
I mean, yeah, people don't know him. But still, you know, he's one of the most significant epidemiologies of the 20th century. So it's a shame that he's not better known. So what happens with Wu's mask after the mentoring play? What does it go? Well, Dr. Wu's design inspired others around the world to try their hand at mask design too.
我的意思是，是的，人们不认识他。不过，他依然是20世纪最重要的流行病学家之一。所以他没有获得更高的知名度，真是一种遗憾。那么在东北鼠疫之后，伍连德的口罩怎么样了？它去哪了？嗯，伍连德的设计启发了世界各地的人们也尝试自己设计口罩。
And so they were competing models. So it becomes kind of a medical competition and design competition for the best mask. You know, it's the holy grail of that epidemic. You know, who is going to produce the best mask, the most efficient mask. And some of them are really, kind of weird things. They look like a divers suit or something. The others have more simple, but who's is the one which prevails?
所以当时有互相竞争的模型。因此它变成了一场关于最佳口罩的医学竞争和设计竞争。你知道，那是那场疫情的圣杯。你知道，谁将生产出最好、最高效的口罩。其中一些设计真的很奇怪。它们看起来像潜水服什么的。其他的则更简单，但伍连德的设计最终胜出。
One of the key things I think about who's design was that it was disposable, so it didn't need to be disinfected. Some of the other designs were just too complicated. That makes sense. So seven years later, when the 1918 flu epidemic hit, masks similar to the ones that Dr. Rue design started being used around the world. This was a device that was globally recognized by doctors as well as the late public as a necessary and efficient anti-contagian device. I don't know how easy it would have been to make people accept these masks and adopt
我认为伍连德设计的一个关键之处在于它是抛弃型的，所以不需要消毒。其他一些设计实在是太复杂了。这就说得通了。因此，七年后，当1918年流感大流行爆发时，类似于伍连德设计的口罩开始在世界各地使用。这是一种被全球医生以及广大公众公认为必要且高效的防传染设备的装置。我不知道如果没有最近成功控制疫情的经历，要让人接受并采用这些口罩会有多容易。
them if it had not been part of a recent outbreak that had been successfully controlled. And during the 1918 flu, Americans wore masks a lot like Dr. Rose. Nancy Toms is a history professor at SUNY Stony Brook, and she's written a lot about the epidemic. She told me about all these great photos of Americans wearing masks during the flu epidemic. So, there's this really wonderful picture of a baseball game in Pasadena, California. And you can see the empire, the catcher, and the picture subbed to that all wearing masks.
在1918年流感期间，美国人大量佩戴类似于伍连德设计的口罩。南希·托姆斯是纽约州立大学石溪分校的历史教授，她撰写了大量关于这次流行病的文章。她向我介绍了许多美国人在流感大流行期间戴口罩的精彩照片。所以，有一张非常精彩的照片，是加利福尼亚州帕萨迪纳的一场棒球比赛。你可以看到裁判、捕手和投球手都戴着口罩。
And then behind them, you can see the spectators also wearing masks. So if people wearing them during a baseball game, like I can barely wear one, like on a brisk walk for a couple blocks. So like, does this mean that everyone was wearing masks at this point? Okay, so to be fair, I think that was the only baseball game where people play it.
然后他们身后，你可以看到观众也戴着口罩。如果人们在看棒球比赛时戴着口罩，就像我勉强能戴着它在街区快走几条街一样。所以，这是否意味着当时每个人都戴着口罩？好吧，公平地说，我想那是唯一一场人们戴着口罩参加的棒球比赛。
Um, it was reported as the first baseball game where players wore masks. And it was probably also the last one. Yeah, so it was a little bit of propaganda to get people to wear. Yeah, it was for show. Professor Tom said that these photos, they're mostly police officers, nurses, but also baseball players and society ladies. They were meant to convince more people to wear masks. So they were like Instagram influencers? Totally.
嗯，据报道这是第一场球员戴口罩的棒球比赛。而且可能也是最后一场。是的，所以这有点像宣传，为了让人们戴口罩。是的，这只是做给别人看的。托姆斯教授说，这些照片中的人大多是警察、护士，但也有棒球运动员和名媛。他们意在说服更多人戴口罩。所以他们就像Instagram网红？完全是。
Totally. Yes. So, I mean, this time around during this pandemic, I've been seeing news items and on social media photos from back in the 1918 pandemic. And you see these photos and it's, I guess it's easy to assume that everyone was wearing the mask, but Professor Tom says we shouldn't assume that it was that universal. It's a more, I don't want to call it an elite practice, but a specialized practice. So you're going to find it among certain groups and they're wearing out of it. It's going to be replicated as a way to make everybody feel calmer and safer. But was the expectation that every American should go around with the Goss mask? I don't think that happened.
完全是。是的。所以，我的意思是，这一次在大流行期间，我一直在新闻和社交媒体上看到1918年大流行时期的照片。你看到这些照片时，很容易让人以为当时每个人都戴着口罩，但托姆斯教授说，我们不应该认为它是那么普遍的。这是一个更倾向于——我不想称之为精英的做法——而是一种特殊的做法。所以你会在某些群体中发现它，他们戴着它。它将被复制，作为一种让每个人都感到更平静、更安全的方式。但当时是否期望每个美国人都戴着纱布口罩到处走？我想并没有发生那样的情景。
Still, local health officials were calling on people to wear masks, and in some cities there were mask ordinances. So if you were caught without one, you were fine or you went to jail. And women were being called upon to sew masks for the cause. Yeah, which is another thing you see today. So right after that 1918 pandemic ended, Americans kind of stopped using masks. So it was just kind of this like blip in American history where it wasn't unusual to wear a mask.
尽管如此，当地的卫生官员仍在呼吁人们戴口罩，在一些城市还有戴口罩的法令。所以如果你被发现没戴口罩，你就会被罚款或进监狱。女性也被号召为这项事业缝制口罩。是的，这也是你在今天能看到的另一个现象。所以在1918年大流行结束后不久，美国人基本上就不再戴口罩了。所以这只是美国历史上的一段小插曲，当时戴口罩并不罕见。
Yeah, masks basically fell into obscurity in the US after that. I mean, there were other epidemics throughout the 20th century, but they weren't spread by coughing and sneezing in the US. But in China, there was never a chance for people to forget masks for too long. First of all, in China, you have a continuity of the use of the mask, right? So the mask story does not end in 1911 or 1918. It continues through several other outbreaks in the 20s and the 30s. And then in Maoist China, after 49, again, the mask plays an important role in public health campaigns.
是的，在此之后，口罩在美国基本上淡出了人们的视野。我的意思是，20世纪还发生过其他流行病，但在美国，它们并不是通过咳嗽和打喷嚏传播的。但在中国，人们从没有机会将口罩遗忘太久。首先，在中国，口罩的使用具有连续性，对吧？所以口罩的故事并没有在1911年或1918年结束。它在20年代和30年代的好几次疫情中延续下来。然后在毛泽东时代的中国，49年以后，口罩在公共卫生运动中再次发挥了重要作用。
You see the masks in a great number of public health propaganda posters. I think this is kind of an important point. A lot of folks would say that wearing a mask is kind of a cultural thing in China. I think that's kind of true, but Vivian Huang was telling me that it's only normalized in China because they were required to wear them by the state.
你在大量的公共卫生宣传海报中都能看到口罩。我认为这是一个很重要的点。很多人会说在中国戴口罩是一种文化现象。我认为这有一定道理，但黄维雯告诉我，口罩之所以在中国被正常化，是因为国家要求他们佩戴。
The government has been through the media, through a lot of these. Huang told me that public health campaigns on neighborhood chalkboards, or posters on telephone poles, all promoted wearing masks. And in the 20s and 30s, Shanghai newspapers, they published articles and cartoons that tried to popularize the use of masks. Yeah, and women's magazines showed masks
政府通过媒体、通过许多这样的渠道。黄告诉我，社区黑板报或电线杆上的海报等公共卫生运动都大力倡导戴口罩。在20年代和30年代，上海的报纸发表了试图普及口罩使用的文章和漫画。是的，女性杂志将口罩
as kind of like a status symbol. And they were, they were these magazine articles, teaching readers, how to knit their own masks. I'm falling for this fashion thing as well, because I have a kind of a more technical store bought mask, like an N95 leftover from the wildfires of California. But I also have a handmade one.
描绘成一种身份的象征。而且当时确实有这样的杂志文章，教读者如何自己织口罩。我也落入了这种时尚的陷阱，因为我有一种更专业的买来的口罩，比如加州山火留下的N95。但我也买了一个手工制作的。
And it might not have the efficacy of the manufactured one, but I like wearing it more, because it's prettier. and it might not have the efficacy of the manufactured one, but I like wearing it more because it's prettier. Exactly, exactly. Like, you're more willing to wear something that you like the way it looks. Yeah, sure. Anyway, through it all,
它可能没有工厂生产的那么有效，但我更喜欢戴它，因为它更好看。而且它可能没有工厂生产的那么有效，但我更喜欢戴它，因为它更好看。完全正确，完全正确。就像，你更愿意戴你喜欢其外观的东西。是的，当然。无论如何，经历了这一切，
Dr. Wu's Gaws mask design or something similar to it survived. And then if we flash forward to the 2002 SARS epidemic, again, masks appeared. Doctors were wearing surgical masks, but Vivian Huang remembers seeing people on the streets wearing masks similar to the ones that Dr. Wu designed. Back then, she said she was a student. She was stuck on lockdown on her university campus in Shanghai. And once again, there were public health campaigns on hand washing and wearing masks. And she says, that's why this time around,
伍博士的纱布口罩设计或与之类似的设计得以保留下来。然后如果我们快进到2002年的SARS疫情，口罩再次出现。医生们戴着医用口罩，但黄维雯记得看到街上的人们戴着类似于伍连德设计的口罩。当时，她说她还是个学生。她被封锁在上海的大学校园里。又一次，开展了关于洗手和戴口罩的公共卫生运动。她说，这就是为什么这一次，
everyone remembered and knew what to do. So it's not exactly that people in China are more inclined culturally to wear a mask. They just had more occasion in recent history, to wear a mask, and so they know what to do, and they know what the deal is. Yeah, exactly. But that's not to say it's been easy for Chinese people to get used to wearing masks. I mean, even this time around at first older people really resisted. That's gonna happen here too, where we're trying to convince our boomer parents to stay in,
每个人都记得并且知道该怎么做。所以，这并不完全是因为中国人在文化上更倾向于戴口罩。他们只是在近代历史上更有机会戴口罩，所以他们知道该怎么做，也知道是怎么回事。是的，完全如此。但这并不是说中国人民习惯戴口罩是一件容易的事。我的意思是，甚至这一次一开始，老年人也真的很抗拒。这种情况也会在这里发生，我们试图说服我们的婴儿潮一代父母呆在家里，
because they were fearful they would die. You know, so. Yeah, and it's the same thing. I mean, younger people here were telling me that at first, they were really having to nag their parents and grandparents to wear masks. And they were joking that they had to nag their older relatives with the same intensity that they were being nagged to get married. So, like direct and relentless. Exactly. They're calling up their family every day, saying,所以 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣就這樣 這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣就這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 這樣就這樣 And now it's to the point where people will just wear them when they've got a cold. It's just normal here.
因为他们害怕自己会死。你知道，所以。是的，情况是一样的。我的意思是，那里的年轻人告诉我，起他们一开始真的不得不唠叨他们的父母和祖父母戴口罩。他们开玩笑说，他们唠叨长辈戴口罩的强度，就像催婚时被唠叨的强度一样。就像直接而无休止的催促。完全如此。他们每天给家里打电话，说……而现在，人们感冒时都会戴上口罩。这在这里很正常。
She said, at least wearing a mask is not strange. You wear it in the winter to keep warm or to protect from pollution or if you have a cold. It's a normalized daily behavior and no one would look at you strangely for choosing to wear one. Yeah, and that really wasn't the case here in the US. I mean, if you were wearing a mask before all this, like, people would wonder why. It seems like that's really starting to change in the past couple weeks. Yeah, I mean, now I would say that maybe, like, 80% of the people in stores are wearing masks and even walking along the street.
她说，至少戴口罩并不奇怪。你在冬天戴它保暖，或者防污染，或者如果你感冒了。这是一种正常化的日常行为，没有人会因为你选择戴口罩而用异样的眼光看你。是的，这在美国绝对不是这样的。我的意思是，如果你在这一切发生之前戴着口罩，人们会想知道为什么。看起来这种情况在过去几周真的开始改变了。是的，我的意思是，现在我要说，可能商店里80%的人都戴着口罩，甚至走在街上也是如此。
I mean, the street thing is that in the Bay Area, we actually have a little bit of a history of wearing in 95 masks because there's wildfires here every year. And so it's not uncommon for people to have a couple in their home to deal with smoke. So I think we were more ready to take on masks, but I've never seen them like this. I mean, it's totally like people are wearing every type of thing, homemade masks, in 95
我的意思是，关于街头的情况是，在湾区，我们其实有一点点佩戴N95口罩的历史，因为这里每年都有山火。所以人们家里备有几个口罩来应付烟雾并不罕见。所以我认为我们对戴口罩做好了更多的准备，但我从未见过像现在这样。我的意思是，这完全就像人们戴着各种各样的东西，自制口罩、N95
masks. They're really everywhere. Yeah, and that's quite different from the past, because I've been hearing from Asian American friends that there was like real trepidation about wearing a mask in public, because the culture of masks is so different or has been so different in the US. There was a lot of fear about how they would be perceived wearing a mask. And Professor Linteres talked about this.
口罩。它们真的是无处不在。是的，这与过去大不相同，因为我从亚裔美国朋友那里听说，在公共场合戴口罩真的让人感到很畏惧，因为美国的口罩文化非常不同，或者说曾经非常不同。人们非常担心戴口罩会被如何看待。林特雷斯教授谈到了这一点。
The masks have become very aggressively and viciously racialized, right? They're associated with China, with Chinese people in a very xenophobic manner. So, xenophobia is basically racism towards ethnically Chinese people. And so, you have this phenomenon where, with some journalists call a mascophobia, which is basically an attribute of xenophobia, people being attacked,
口罩已经变得非常具有攻击性和恶意地被种族化了，对吧？它们以一种非常仇外的态度与中国、与中国人民联系在一起。所以，仇外心理基本上就是对华裔人群的种族歧视。因此，你就会遇到这样一种现象，一些记者称之为“口罩恐惧症”，这基本上是仇外心理的一种属性，人们遭到袭击，
like people who look Chinese or who look Asian, being attacked on the streets of London and other places because they're wearing masks. Professor Lintero says this kind of insidious racism isn't even recognized by most people, but it's always been connected with disease. So from the very birth of xenophobia in the modern Europe and America, xenophobia has been connected with this idea of epidemics coming from China and being spread by Chinese people. Right. And I think that the mask and maskophobia is kind of a, is tied to this, to this racist and xenophobic attitudes. But in China, there's no maskophobia.
比如看起来像中国人或亚洲人的人，在伦敦和其他地方的街头因为戴着口罩而遭到袭击。林特雷斯教授说，这种潜在的种族主义甚至没有被大多数人意识到，但它一直与疾病联系在一起。因此，从现代欧洲和美洲仇外心理诞生之初，仇外心理就一直与这种流行病源自中国并由中国人民传播的观点联系在一起。没错。我认为口罩和口罩恐惧症与这种种族主义和仇外心理有关。但在中国，没有口罩恐惧症。
It's people who aren't wearing masks during this pandemic that are seen as strange. It is, you know, the baseline as it were of self protection, but more importantly, it's not so much about protecting yourself against being infected. It is more of protecting others. I think this is something I didn't really fully appreciate at the beginning of all this. I mean, I think I had this instinct that when people were in mass before that they were trying to protect themselves, they were really worried about their own health when it came to a pandemic.
在这个大流行期间不戴口罩的人才会被视为奇怪。这，你知道，可以说是自我保护的底线，但更重要的是，这与其说是为了保护自己免受感染，不如说是为了保护他人。我认为这是我在这一切开始时没有真正充分理解的事情。我的意思是，我想我有这样一种直觉，当人们以前戴着口罩时，他们是想保护自己，当涉及到流行病时，他们真的很担心自己的健康。
But the truth is, it's like the opposite of that. Like they have a little bit of cold and they don't want to spread it to you. A mask does a really good job of keeping them from spreading it to you. They're protecting me. Exactly, they're being conscientious. Yeah.
但事实是，这恰恰相反。就像他们有点感冒，不想传染给你一样。口罩在阻止他们传染给你方面做得非常好。他们在保护我。完全正确，他们很有公德心。是的。
So have you gotten used to wearing a mask regularly? Yeah. I mean, it's definitely not fun to wear a mask. I mean, I'm not gonna lie. I mean, I have glasses wearing masks just to... Oh, I've got to say that. Oh, it's the worst. Yeah, it's tough.
那你习惯经常戴口罩了吗？是的。我的意思是，戴口罩绝对不好玩。我的意思是，我不会撒谎。我的意思是，我戴着眼镜戴口罩简直……哦，我得说说这个。哦，这太糟糕了。是的，这很难。
My glasses are always fogged up and I hated wearing them on polluted days in Shanghai. They made me feel really depressed. But during this outbreak, I'm really surprised. They do not make me feel depressed. And I feel like seeing everyone around me wearing a mask, I feel like a sense of solidarity. I mean, I can't see their face. I can't see their whole face. But I feel like we're telling each other I'm watching out for you.
我的眼镜总是起雾，我在上海空气污染的日子里讨厌戴口罩。它们让我感到非常沮丧。但在这场疫情期间，我真的很惊讶。它们没有让我感到沮丧。我觉得看到周围每个人都戴着口罩，我有一种团结感。我的意思是，我看不见他们的脸。我看不清他们的整张脸。但我感觉我们在告诉彼此：我在守护你。
Right. Right. And I mean, I'm paying much more attention to people's eyes because that's how I can tell what their expression is. Right, you can see that they're smiling. Yeah, so I mean, when I see other people wearing a mask, I feel like it's a reminder that we're all in this together. Coming up, individual people are not the only ones changing their habits to deal with coronavirus.
没错。没错。而且，我的意思是，我更加关注人们的眼睛，因为这就是我判断他们表情的方式。没错，你能看出他们在笑。是的，所以，当我看到其他人戴着口罩时，我觉得这是一个提醒，提醒我们都在同一条船上。接下来，个人并不是唯一改变习惯以应对冠状病毒的人。
Manufacturers are also finding themselves in uncharted waters, switching to produce the masks and gowns and ventilators that we need so desperately. Some stories of the great manufacturing pivot of 2020. After this. About three weeks ago, Tyler Mentel was in a home depot at 6am, taking his first steps and trying to solve a huge global problem. Just looking at just a wall of parts and pieces and hoses, just trying to figure out what I could put together to put together a baseline ventilator. A mechanical ventilator that could assist someone who has trouble breathing because they have COVID-19.
制造商也发现自己身处未知的领域，转而生产我们迫切需要的口罩、防护服和呼吸机。2020年大制造转型的故事。广告之后继续。大约三周前，泰勒·曼特尔（Tyler Mentel）在早上6点来到一家家得宝（Home Depot），迈出了他试图解决一个巨大全球问题的第一步。只是看着一堵零件和软管的墙，只是想弄清楚我可以把什么拼凑在一起，拼凑出一个基准呼吸机。一个可以帮助呼吸困难的人的机械呼吸机，因为他们感染了COVID-19。
And when anytime you're starting a design process, you need something. As you're communicating with teams, the first thing you put together allows people to understand direction, it defines things you never thought you'd define. So just having a physical construct can always be very helpful. So Tyler and his colleagues are in the home deep out and none of the stuff on the wall is designed for ventilators. Staring at a wall of one wave valves for PET connections, like they didn't fit onto what we were using at all, they were silly, but they, and they were the wrong pressure grade, that everything was wrong about it.
而且无论何时你开始设计过程，你都需要一些东西。当你与团队沟通时，你组装的第一件事可以让人们了解方向，它定义了你从未想过要定义的事情。所以有一个物理结构总是非常有帮助的。因此，泰勒和他的同事们在家得宝，墙上的所有东西都不是为呼吸机设计的。盯着一堵用于PET连接的单向阀的墙，它们根本不适合我们正在使用的东西，它们很蠢，而且它们的压力等级不对，关于它的一切都是错的。
But we needed to understand what it is we were working with. It was interesting. It was a throwback to the scene in Apollo 13. This is the scene where the mission control technicians have to figure out how to fit a square filter into a round hole using only the items that can be found in the Apollo 13 spacecraft or all the astronauts are going to die. Okay people, listen up, people upstairs, Canada is this one and we gotta come through.
但我们需要了解我们在处理什么。这很有趣。这让人想起《阿波罗13号》中的场景。这是任务控制技术人员必须想方设法将方形过滤器塞进圆形孔洞的场景，只能使用阿波罗13号飞船上能找到的物品，否则所有宇航员都会死。好了，大家听着，楼上的人，加拿大是这个，我们得想办法挺过去。
We gotta find a way to make this fit into the hole for this. Use it nothing but that. Damn, that's the greatest scene in movie history. Anyway. We just started throwing stuff in a cart. I think I put 150, 200 bucks on my credit card and ran a bunch of stuff to the lab. And we started piling things together until it made our first iteration of ventilator. As you can tell, Tyler Mantell doesn't normally make ventilators.
我们必须想办法把这个塞进这个孔里。只能用那个。见鬼，那是电影史上最伟大的场景。不管怎样。我们只是开始把东西扔进购物车里。我想我把150、200美元刷在信用卡上，把一堆东西带回了实验室。然后我们开始把东西堆在一起，直到它做出了我们的第一个呼吸机迭代版。如你所见，泰勒·曼特尔平时并不制造呼吸机。
So most of the time I make robots that swim through water pipes to find leaks. This is a huge problem with old infrastructure. 20% of the world's clean water is lost to leaky pipes, but suddenly that wasn't the most pressing problem in the world. When coronavirus came and hit us like it did, the ability to travel and do some of the big projects we have coming up went away. So we started to look at what else we could do. And my co-founder of the ventilator project is actually also my roommate.
所以大多数时候我制造在水管中游动以寻找泄漏的机器人。这是旧基础设施的一个巨大问题。世界上20%的干净水都因水管泄漏而白白流失，但突然之间，这不再是世界上最紧迫的问题。当冠状病毒爆发并像这样袭击我们时，旅行和开展我们即将进行的某些大项目的能力消失了。所以我们开始寻找我们还能做些什么。呼吸机项目的联合创始人其实也是我的室友。
We work in the same building and we just started talking about the fact that ventilators are gonna be a huge shortage. And so I started digging into it and you start to find out that a ventilator is not a difficult product. The lack of difficulty doesn't mean it's easy. It means it's straightforward. So Tyler and his co-founder at the ventilator Project, Alex Frost, assembled a team of over
我们在同一栋楼里工作，我们开始讨论呼吸机将出现严重短缺的问题。所以我开始深入研究，你开始发现呼吸机并不是一个困难的产品。不困难并不意味着它很容易。这意味着它很简单。因此，泰勒和他在呼吸机项目的联合创始人亚历克斯·弗罗斯特（Alex Frost）组建了一个由200多名
200 remote, volunteer engineers, medical regulatory, and business professionals to try and help solve the global Venelator shortage as fast as possible. And even though the details from company to company are very different, a lot of manufacturers are making a similar pivot. If you're a manufacturer that's kind of what you're always looking like, can we make something like that? Can we make that? That's sort of inner blood. This is Matt Henderson, the co-founder of Sound Devices. They normally make high-end audio mixing and recording consoles.
远程志愿者工程师、医疗监管和商业专业人士组成的团队，试图以尽可能快的速度帮助解决全球呼吸机短缺问题。尽管不同公司的细节大不相同，但许多制造商都在做类似的转变。如果你是一个制造商，这正是你一直在寻找的，我们可以制造那样东西吗？我们可以制造那个吗？这某种程度上流淌在我们的血液里。这是马特·亨德森（Matt Henderson），声卡设备公司（Sound Devices）的联合创始人。他们通常制造高端音频混音和录音控制台。
A couple of weeks ago, I was texting back and forth with my head of manufacturing, Lisa, and said, you know, I wonder if we could make ventilators or masks or something. They ended up concentrating on facial masks. I came in and talked to my sales guys and said, hey, do you guys want to call some hospitals and see if this is true about there being a shortage. Because I don't know. And they made some calls and they came back and they said, yeah, definitely hospitals really need these badly. So that's, you know, a few minutes later, we just started buying parts. You know, that was on a Monday that we started that. And then it was 32
几周前，我和我的制造主管丽莎（Lisa）发短信来回交流，我说，你知道，我想知道我们是否可以制造呼吸机或口罩之类的东西。他们最终专注于面部口罩。我进来和我的销售人员谈过，说，嘿，你们想不想给一些医院打电话，看看关于短缺的传闻是不是真的。因为我不知道。他们打了一些电话，然后回来告诉我，是的，绝对的，医院真的很需要这些。所以，你知道，几分钟后，我们开始购买零件。你知道，我们是周一开始的。然后是32
hours later. We had the first ones coming off the end of the line. And today if you go to the product page on sounddevices.com you can order a 32 channel 36 track mixer and a 100 pack of single use medical face shields. And much like the ventilator project when Matt described his company's pivot to our producer and it fits Gerald who you'll hear in the next clip. It wasn't the technology or the know how needed to make the product that was the hard part. You take the foam sticking on there, staple on the elastic and you're done.
小时后。我们生产线的第一批产品下线了。今天，如果你去 sounddevices.com 的产品页面，你可以订购一个32通道36轨混音器和一包100个的一次性医用面罩。就像呼吸机项目一样，当马特向我们的制片人安·菲茨杰拉德（Ann FitzGerald）描述他公司的转变时（你将在下一个片段中听到），难点并不是制造产品所需的技术或专业知识。你拿着贴在上面的泡沫，把松紧带订上去，就完成了。
It sounds really simple. But getting these three parts in volume has been difficult. So we have supplier, it's our normal suppliers for the plastic shield and for the foam. Luckily we've got great suppliers for them. They're right nearby in Wisconsin and we buy them and that's all great. The elastic piece that's been kind of a nightmare to get in quantity. I'll give you for instance, last week two of our purchasing people, Lorraine and Chignier were driving all around Northern Wisconsin going from Walmart to Walmart and Joanne's fabric to Joanne's fabric, buying up all the elastic they could find.
听起来真的很简单。但要大批量生产这三个部件却很困难。所以我们有供应商，这是我们塑料面罩和海绵的常规供应商。幸运的是，我们有很棒的供应商。他们就在威斯康星州附近，我们从他们那里购买，这都很好。松紧带这种东西，要大量进货简直是一场噩梦。我举个例子，上周我们的两个采购人员，洛林和奇尼尔，开车跑遍了威斯康星州北部，从一家沃尔玛到另一家沃尔玛，从一家乔安面料店到另一家乔安面料店，买光了他们能找到的所有松紧带。
I feel like when you picture manufacturing, you don't picture the manufacturer's driving to Joanne's fabrics to get the stuff they're making. Well, and normally you don't picture the manufacturer, it's driving to Jillian Fabrics to get the stuff they're making. Well, and normally you don't. But this is a special situation, right? Right, so yeah. Right, right. It's typical when you call, you say, I want to buy this much foam, and they say, lead time is six weeks, and you go, okay, no problem, you plan for that.
我觉得当你想象制造业时，你不会想到制造商会开车去乔安面料店购买他们正在制造的东西。嗯，通常你不会想到制造商开车去吉莉安面料店购买他们正在制造的东西。嗯，通常不会。但这是一种特殊情况，对吧？对，所以，是的。对，对。通常当你打电话时，你会说，我想买这么多海绵，然后他们会说，交货时间是六周，然后你会说，好的，没问题，你为此做计划。
Well, in this pandemic, six weeks does us no good. Supply chains, regulations, and factories have to be more nimble than ever before because the virus is a moving target. Just ask Jen Garino, CEO of the Industrial Sowing and Innovation Center in Detroit, which normally makes fashion a barrel. I will tell you that this has been such a quickly changing normally makes fashion a barrel. I will tell you that this has been such a quickly changing environment. At first, it was mass, mass, mass, mass. So we sampled all these mass, all these mass. And then it was no longer mass.
好吧，在这场大流行中，六周对我们毫无用处。供应链、法规和工厂必须比以往任何时候都更加灵活，因为病毒是一个移动的目标。问问底特律工业缝纫与创新中心（Industrial Sowing and Innovation Center）的首席执行官简·加里诺（Jen Garino）就知道了，该中心通常生产时尚服装。我得告诉你，这是一个变化如此之快的环境。一开始是口罩、口罩、口罩、口罩。所以我们对所有这些口罩进行了采样，所有这些口罩。然后就不再是口罩了。
It was really gowns. And gowns has really turned out to be the big problem and really what we're most suited to make. And what is an isolation gown, exactly? So an isolation gown is, there's varying degrees. And trust me, when I say, I have learned a lot in the last three weeks I have wow. I mean acronyms I didn't know before the whole thing What makes an isolation gown is that it has
真的成了防护服。事实证明，防护服确实成了大问题，也是我们最适合制造的产品。那么，隔离衣到底是什么？所以隔离衣有不同的程度。相信我，当我说，我在过去三周里学到了很多，我简直惊呆了。我是说那些我以前不知道的缩写词。隔离衣的特点在于它有
particulate protection to varying degrees So if you're in surgery you have you know really tight cuffs around your wrist and tied around your neck and you know You know highest grade material and the level one is just sort of like a sheath that you put over that just, you know, helps you a little bit. The industrial sewing and innovation center, also known as Isaac, was already a mission-driven company before coronavirus. So the industrial sewing and innovation center is designed to be a people-centered institute that trains people for advanced manufacturing of some goods like a peril. And to do so in a way that is responsible, the fashion series is a very polluting
不同程度的颗粒防护。所以如果你在手术中，你知道手腕上有非常紧的袖口，系在脖子上，你知道，你知道最高级别的材料，而一级材料只是一种套在你身上的护套，它只，你知道，对你有一点帮助。工业缝纫与创新中心，也被称为艾萨克（Isaac），在冠状病毒出现之前就已经是一家有使命感的公司了。因此，工业缝纫与创新中心旨在成为一个以人为本的机构，培训人们进行先进制造，比如服装等一些商品。并以负责任的方式这样做，时尚产业是一个非常污染的
irresponsible industry for the most part. It puts about 45 billion units of garments in Delanfields every year before a consumer. One of the solutions to changing these bad practices is to manufacture closer to home. So instead of stores speculatively buying clothes, they think will sell nine months in the future. They use more advanced and local manufacturing to quickly fulfill orders on
绝大多数是不负责任的行业。在消费者买到之前，它每年向垃圾填埋场倾倒约 450 亿件服装。改变这些不良做法的解决方案之一是在离家较近的地方进行制造。因此，商店不再推测性地购买他们认为会在九个月后畅销的衣服。他们利用更先进的本地制造来快速完成订单，满足
demand. So you get rid of a whole waste stream and now you have a whole resource pool that you can now allocate to paying higher wages. And being sustainable, from that standpoint, we really believe that having a sustainable product is not sustainable, unless the people making them have sustainable lives. You can't fight every battle at the same time, right? I totally get that. But how have you approached balancing your mission to the moment?
需求。因此，你消除了整个废物流，现在你拥有了一个完整的资源池，你可以将其分配给支付更高的工资。从这个角度来看，要保持可持续发展，我们坚强地认为，除非制造产品的人拥有可持续的生活，否则产品本身的可持续发展是不可持续的。你不可能同时打赢每一场仗，对吧？我完全理解这一点。但是你是如何平衡你的使命与当下的呢？
That's right. You can't make everything first priority. Sustainability, I will have to tell you right now, is not our number one priority because we're working on polypropylene. These are disposable gowns. You wear them once and you throw them out. It's the opposite of sustainable. No, but we have learned a lot about how that stuff gets recycled.
没错。你不能把每件事都放在第一位。我现在必须告诉你，可持续性不是我们的首要任务，因为我们正在加工聚丙烯。这些是一次性隔离衣。你穿一次就扔掉。这与可持续发展截然相反。不，但我们已经了解到很多关于这些材料如何被回收利用的知识。
So we're learning as we go about these waste streams and what you can do about these waste streams. So it's interesting that even though we're creating where ways we're also understanding what you do with it when it's done, But I think what hasn't changed is our commitment to training people and treating people differently than they've been treated in a factory environment. So we're just making different products. So how do you physically make the factory safe so that workers can be separate and still do their jobs? Ah, good question.
所以我们在摸索中了解这些废物流以及你可以对这些废物流做些什么。所以很有趣的是，尽管我们在制造废物，但我们也理解当它完成时你该如何处理它，但我认为没有改变的是我们培训员工的承诺，以及以不同于工厂环境中的方式对待员工。所以我们只是在制造不同的产品。那么，你如何从物理上确保工厂的安全，以便工人可以保持距离并继续完成工作？啊，问得好。
Yeah. So, one of the things that we had to do is when you're manufacturing in a lean way, you reduce costs by reducing the space by which you hand things to each other. So, in a typical cell, a cell is a team of people working on different parts of an item. Once the items do the cell, it's completed. Literally, you have pieces of fabric that are tied together, that are kind of making their way around, you know, the cell. So you're very, very, very close and that's how you remain competitive. So we had to distance that.
是的。所以，我们必须做的事情之一是，当你以精益的方式进行制造时，你通过减少彼此传递物品的空间来降低成本。因此，在一个典型的单元中，单元是一组协同工作的人，负责处理物品的不同部分。一旦物品通过该单元，它就完成了。从字面上看，你拥有用线捆绑在一起的织物碎片，它们在单元周围移动。所以你们非常非常非常近，这就是你们保持竞争力的方式。所以我们必须拉开距离。
So literally, what we did was we had these brand new, gorgeous machines that, you know, get, are, they're programmable, they're really beautiful. And in between them, we've rigged these corrugated cardboard pathways, duct tape, between machines so that we can create enough distance at least six feet to pass the material cross and then to wear a mask in the glove. So it's been this real, you know, just figure it out, make it work. As we continue to navigate the pandemic, notably without the proper planning and guidance from our federal executive, we're lying on the ingenuity and generosity of these manufacturers
所以实际上，我们所做的是拥有这些全新的、华丽的机器，你知道，它们是可编程的，真的很漂亮。在它们之间，我们在机器之间用胶带固定了这些瓦楞纸板通道，这样我们就可以创造足够的距离，至少六英尺，来传递材料，然后戴上口罩和手套。所以这真的是那种，你知道，摸索着解决，让它发挥作用。在我们继续应对大流行的过程中，尤其是缺乏我们联邦行政部门的适当规划和指导的情况下，我们依赖这些制造商的创造力和慷慨
to fill in the gaps. There will be a lot of just figuring it out. Define out more about the ventilator project, sound devices, and the industrial sewing and innovation center, go to 99mpi.org. 99% Invisible's impact design coverage is supported by Autodesk. Autodesk enables the design and creation
来填补空白。会有很多摸索。要了解有关呼吸机项目、声学设备和工业缝纫与创新中心的更多信息，请访问 99mpi.org。99% Invisible 的影响力设计报道得到了 Autodesk 的支持。Autodesk 支持设计和创造
of innovative solutions to the world's most pressing, social, and environmental challenges. To address the shortage of personal protective equipment, Autodesk is helping connect design and manufacturing resources to develop new solutions for PPE and life-saving devices. Learn more about these efforts at Autodesk.com-slaughtredshift, a site that tells stories about the future of making things across architecture, engineering, infrastructure, construction, and manufacturing. I have a special announcement. We have a book coming out. It's by Kurt Colstead and me, and illustrated by Patrick Veil.
针对世界上最紧迫的社会和环境挑战的创新解决方案。为了解决个人防护装备短缺的问题，Autodesk 正在帮助连接设计和制造资源，以开发用于 PPE 和救生设备的新解决方案。在 Autodesk.com-slaughtredshift 上了解有关这些努力的更多信息，这是一个讲述跨建筑、工程、基础设施、施工和制造的事物制造未来的故事的网站。我有一个特别的公告。我们要出一本书。它由库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）和我撰写，帕特里克·维尔（Patrick Veil）插图。
It's called the 99% Invisible City. When we're back outside and ready to appreciate the everyday design of the city and broader world around us, this will be your guide. It comes out on October 6th from Houghton, Mifflin Harcord, and right now you can see the beautiful cover and find links to pre-order it on our website. It's 999PI.org, slash book. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Rebecca Canther, Emmett Fitzgerald, and Vivian Leigh.
它被称为《99% 隐形城市》（The 99% Invisible City）。当我们回到户外并准备欣赏我们周围城市和更广阔世界的日常设计时，这将是你的指南。它将于 10 月 6 日由霍顿·米夫林·哈考特（Houghton Mifflin Harcord）出版，现在你可以在我们的网站上看到漂亮的封面并找到预订它的链接。它是 999PI.org，斜杠书（slash book）。本周的 99% Invisible 由丽贝卡·坎瑟（Rebecca Canther）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）和维维安·李（Vivian Leigh）制作。
Mix and Tech production by Shreve Usif, Music by Sean Real. Katie Mingle is our senior producer Kirk Colestead, the digital director. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Barouba, Avery Trouffleman, Sophia Klatscher, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K LW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is distributed in multiple East Bay apartments, but in our heart it is located in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a proud founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective
混音和技术制作由什里夫·乌西夫（Shreve Usif）负责，音乐由肖恩·雷尔（Sean Real）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的高级制片人库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kirk Colstead），数字总监。团队的其他成员包括高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、克里斯·巴鲁巴（Chris Barouba）、埃弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Trouffleman）、索菲亚·克拉彻（Sophia Klatscher）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山 91.7K LW 的一个项目，在 Radio Row 制作，该项目分布在东湾的多间公寓里，但在我们的心中，它位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是来自 PRX 的 Radio Topia 的骄傲创始成员，这是一个由
of the most innovative listener-supported podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI Ork, run Instagram and read it too. We have design stories, upon design stories, and a link and view of the brand new book at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
世界上最具创新性的听众支持的播客组成的坚定的独立集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，在 99PI Ork 上@该节目，也可以在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上找到我们。我们有关于设计的故事，关于设计的故事，以及在 99PI.org 上的新书链接和预览。Radio Tapio。来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。